a terrified Florida mother placed a  frantic 911 11-foot alligator my  goodness the teen was floating on a raft  Friday near the Ocala National Forest  when a large Gator emerged and pursued  her well she climbed up a hanging branch  clung to the tree for 30 minutes as the  dangerous reptile stood hissing a few  feet away the sheriff's deputy  eventually arrived and shot the Gator  with a rifle as it moved toward him the  teen climbed down safely and no people  were hurt you can really hear the  anguish as a mom yeah terrifying moment  and they got and then somebody told me  Gators can climb trees very well in for  now not in this case